until about 1902 legal food
preservatives included chemicals like
formaldehyde borax and copper sulfate
that is until one guy organized a poison
supper club to stop it and became the
father of the FDA mm-hmm
okay here's the story in order to keep
food looking fresh food manufacturers
used a slew of chemicals copper sulfate
a common pesticide made canned peas
bright green borax and formaldehyde were
packed with meat to make it appear
fresher at this time in our history
there were no true food regulations you
didn't need to label your ingredients
there was no safety testing no
monitoring thank you dr. Harvey W Wylie
a chemist with the crazy idea that these
chemicals had no place in our food he
started some hygienic lab trials where
he could officially test the effects of
these poisons on the body it was easy to
get the chemicals but he needed the
bodies and that's where the poison squad
came in the first 12 members of the
poison squad were volunteers from the
Department of Agriculture and they
volunteered to eat his poison food for
six months so he could track the effects
it had on them each day the menus would
change and Wiley's volunteers never knew
which poison they were consuming a
dinner at the poison supper club might
look like this applesauce soup turkey
can string the sweet potato white potato
chip beet red and butter coffee rice
pudding and a little board
throughout the trials Wylie noted signs
of acute poisoning including upset
stomachs nausea diarrhea vomiting kidney
damage you know things that happen when
you get poisoned and this did not stay
hidden the press caught on and in 1906
the first food regulations were passed
this ultimately led to the creation of
the FDA so thanks dr. Wylie our food is
so much better without all that borax
you